Jaime's more cerebral he's really smart
you know emotionally as well and and
he's so full he he's a he's a thinkers
he's a deep thinker doesn't just think
about like right here intuitive personal
connection he thinks you know in a more
worldly way and and he's goofy to
working with Shannon purser that had to
be such an amazing gift right um just
tell me what the dynamic was like for
you she's just this real person you know
and she's present she's with you when
you're with her and that's something
that I don't that you don't really find
in a lot of people sometimes they hear
but they're like distant and yeah I
remember the phone conversations we were
both on other ends of the phone well I
was just in a different room and it
wasn't even acting like you sitting
there talking like you're like like you
like someone you have a true connection
with and and and she's just so available
to that and open to that and I feel
blessed to be able to work with it hey
so how was your day the video like at
all maybe we should try again another
time one of the most endearing
characteristics that I like is that he
loved this girl from the inside out I
know was a bit of a catfish no but the
end what do you think people learn from
in dating from your character in that
movie oh yeah I think I think that
there's a really there's a there's a
great message as far as like even in
this cyber stage like social interaction
where it's just all technology you can
still have some level of intimacy over
the phone
preferably like when you're calling it's
really hard to have like that like when
you're texting I mean I do is we talked
for hours and hours and hours on the
phone and that's when we got to know
each other that's when we fell in love
one of the funniest things are these
text messages that are sent out have you
accidentally sent a text and regretted
it instantly oh yeah I'm sure it's
terrible right you get that like string
of panicked
is just right through your whole being
you're like ah there's really no way you
can come back for that you just got to
own it
there's no recovery oh I feel like I'm
so sorry
XYZ
[Music]